while other african nations have
struggled to obtain sufficient vaccine
supplies officials blame production
difficulties and vaccine hoarding by
high-income countries but logistical
problems also mean jobs often don't
reach less populated areas dw's young
philip schultz has this report from a
remote region in kenya
the action finally gets going under the
large mango tree the traditional meeting
point in the small village of oui in
western kenya
nurse harriet and her team hope to
vaccinate 200 villagers against covet
19.
their plan almost fell through
the village is more than an hour from
the nearest clinic and up to the last
moment the team didn't know whether they
would get a vehicle for today's
vaccination campaign at times when we
don't have the vehicle we normally use
motorbikes
to go to the interior villages
because now we we really want to go
vaccinate them but then at the same time
we don't have the means so it's forces
are to use to use their motorbikes but
again motorbikes are not safe with our
vaccine carriers so that's why sometimes
if it's so hard we just wait for support
support that should actually come from
the capital nairobi 500 kilometers away
just a few months ago the biggest
problem was that richer countries were
not sending enough vaccines
today the capital is well stocked but
the government doesn't have a plan to
get the vaccines to remote parts of the
country
amnesty international activist diana
kichango finds it scandalous that the
most vulnerable people are being
neglected
[Music]
the few people in the middle class who
understood
why we needed the vaccine
took all measures to jump the kill
and that left us falling very very far
behind in terms of
focusing on the priority population
another problem is that many kenyans
don't want to be vaccinated at all
conspiracy theories about rich countries
wanting to halt population growth in
africa through vaccinations are going
viral on social media
fact checker alfonse shiondu tries to
counter online fake news he's shocked
that even politicians are promoting
rumors
one especially controversial video
features the minister of health in
neighbouring tanzania so she's
addressing on why this is very important
to for them to use alternative medicines
why we should not
trust
western medicine and stuff like that
that
was very very potentially dangerous and
very very misleading in the way it was
tied because she's saying no vaccines in
tanzania we don't have covet check this
and you will be safe from any viral
infection
in the small village of uwari too just a
few villagers are waiting under the
mango tree for a jab
harriet and her team didn't reach their
target for today
in the end they only managed 130 rather
than the planned 200 vaccinations
they plan to go out to the villages
again tomorrow
if they can get the van
sergios
is an associate professor in cellular
and molecular sciences at northumbria
university in the uk doctor a very warm
welcome
back to dw news because we spoke a year
ago actually
about covet 19 and it is still very much
here what role do you think vaccine
inequality played in the spread of this
new variant omicron
i think it's quite clear that the hub
central vaccination in developing
nations allowed
the emergence of new virus and we got
the warning shot with delta in that a
variant that was highly transmissible
basically uh was able to develop itself
in india and now um
not yet not a year on actually about
nine months on we have a new variant
that is sort of delta plus you know
omega variant which has uh much higher
apparent transvisibility than delta
and it has the capacity to
lead to an overwhelming of healthcare
systems in the developed world now if we
had
done what would what the
virology and vaccinology community had
asked which was to equitably distribute
vaccines worldwide and to sustain the
mitigation measures so that we do not
get transmission anywhere in the world
then we would be very unlikely to be
seeing this situation right now
uh unfortunately here we are we have uh
now this omicron variant um it transmits
a lot it's likely going to lead to a lot
of cases hopefully will not lead us to a
position where we will need another
lockdown
but we can't say right now because if
you got too many cases then you will
have too many people who need
hospitalization and if you don't have a
vaccine
to boost your capacity to be protected
and not become diseased then your
chances of ending up in hospital are
going to be much higher
now the world panicked and as a result
blanket travel bans were introduced as a
scientist do you think
travel bans like that are are the right
tool
right at the beginning of an outbreak
where you have a handful of people of a
disease that can be potentially
contained very quickly for example by
locking down wuhan at the time it nearly
happened
it might work
but when you have already a variant
that's transmitting in the community as
has been demonstrated in the uk and as
i'm sure the rest of europe will
demonstrate soon as the united states is
abruptly demonstrating already it's
pointless it's it's it's literally
pointless to try and prevent
reintroductions of these variant
this would work if we implemented a
lockdown in the countries where omicron
is already present and we implemented a
border control but at this point in time
when we're not prepared to lock down the
economy and communities and societies uh
the the border controls are futile
uh doctor people are very excited about
the developments of anti-virals there
are a few in the pipeline and some are
awaiting emergency approval will they be
the tool out of this pandemic
i i just want to urge a little bit of
caution to this uh it all depends on how
quickly
you are diagnosed from the point where
you show symptoms typically with
antivirals
especially for these kind of diseases
you want this to be administered as
quickly as possible after symptoms show
the same day if if at all possible now
if you fail a lateral load test and you
do an rtpcr test typically it's 24 to 48
hours before you get the result so those
of us who are conscious of our health
are better off getting tested as quickly
as possible when we have a new set of
symptoms and get that result as quickly
as possible if we want to choose the
antiviral pathway
for treatment but frankly there are
vaccines out there available to prevent
you from becoming diseased in the first
place and having a you know 10 days 14
days worth of your life
affected as a minimum if you get long
covered it could be months or you know
potentially even more than a year before
you could get full recovery doctor final
thought i just have a couple of seconds
left we're at the cusp of 2022. are we
in it for the long haul is this a
marathon
i'm afraid so the viruses in animals in
many different wild animals and it will
remain there
so we need to
make use of the tools that we have uh to
the best of our capacity and i note the
the dispatch you have just previously
talked about misinformation uh in africa
and um use of you know magic potions to
solve all biology problems that thing
doesn't exist but what we can't say for
sure is that the the way we solved the
ebola pandemic in africa was through
education now we did it once in africa
we can do it again in our countries and
we can do it again in africa because we
need to move on and get our economy back
on onto the right footing all right dr
stergyos
associate professor in cellular and
molecular sciences at northumbria
university in the united kingdom thank
you very much
you're very welcome